[Music]
and I wonder if we could look at the
anglo-american tradition in particular
what are the particular problems with
that well I would say there may be the
main problem with the anglo-american
tradition is that it doesn't exist the I
mean I you know what people sometimes
use that phrase when what they have in
mind is is analytic philosophy yeah but
analytic philosophy is is practiced in
in most countries in the the world now
as I know from from my travels it's it's
it's and it did not originate in in in
Britain or America it probably you know
arguably originated in Germany because
it happens and you know and now it's
practiced in India in China in in Russia
or and and so so there there is no
specific anglo-american tradition I mean
it's true that as well the tradition of
analytic philosophy tends to be done in
English but the reason for that is that
English has become the international
language of science so it's not
something specific about that
philosophical tradition yeah um I
actually agree that there isn't one
anglo-american tradition at all and in
fact verifying it as an anglo-american
tradition erases how much it has
borrowed from and learned from the
colonial encounter encounters of people
before it and so although we often
thought about the anglo-american
tradition and within that tradition
there's so many did so there's the
analytical treasures but there's also
the Continental tradition which is
technically the European tradition but
it they bleed into one another so the
problem is actually not the tradition in
itself but how it has emerged and
established itself and what it elides
and the erasers it is kind of built upon
that's how I see it
do we need to update that tradition or
do we need to stop thinking about it in
the way we do yeah I think we absolutely
need to constantly update all traditions
and all I mean one of the things about
tradition is that tradition traditions
will go on and what is traditional today
might not be traditional in 20 years
time so I think we need to constantly
check and update our biases and that
doesn't need to be always a right way to
fix that but as long as we're aware and
as long as we're a little bit more
modest about our claims I think yeah
that's weird yeah but and it's also I
mean I this is not disagreeing with what
you said but it's also the case that
within a tradition you you have to use
the methods of that tradition to
recognize your biases and as where the
what one hopes well with a robust
tradition is that it's got the resources
to to renew and correct itself and of
course sometimes traditions get stuck in
a dead-end where they where they can't
do that and that's that's where it
becomes very problematic because you
just they just can't recognize their own
limitations for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you